et maintenant
temps
enfin robert leonard
herbert léonard
trop de l'homme
j'adore cette chanson c'est vraiment une
chose il ya le perce une chanson géniale
le père pour la musique
evelyne buggy pour les paroles et la
production chez le chien voilà alain
bernard pour le champ bordant le nouvel
album d'herbert léonard
il ya la version groupe 2004 2 pour le
plaisir et c'est pas mal
voyez
sans en rien le lait
est ce qu'elle est
ouf
il ya ça aussi à jetons
notre dossier
oh
la m 2
que
le voilà hervé renard je tombe extrait
de entre charme et beauté voilà herbert
léonard qu'on a appelé le barry white
français comme toi que je la vois un peu
moins graves comme les non mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya des trucs quand il il ya
des choses très barry white
j'écoutais l'intro de musique érotique
on dirait vraiment de la musique de film
porno 1
alors j'ai voulu y aller parce que l'on
fait pas toujours gaffe obasi écoute
bien sentir ta bouche effronté c'est un
début épouse et tous mes rêves dans un
délicieux va et vient et doucement
décalotter fini fini bien ici je n'ai
qu'un pays celui de ton corps je n'ai
qu'un péché son triangle d'or
franchement est-ce que c'est pas beau ça
bravo herbert
près d un an après ce raid sur m6 le
dimanche soir
kc x 600 pixels pense que les 850 sur
nous je tiens à le préciser les formes
en station pour les adresser à mme une
biguine parce que celle qui a écrit
n'était qu'à ils sont bien les textes et
ça c'est qui qu'a fait ça j'adore c'est
excite pas lieu qu'est ce qui fait que
c'est celle des gens discrets chômage
c'était quoi le triangle d'or j'ai pas
vu la forme je crois qu'il faut refaire
son éducation sexuelle dans la ronde et
le magic j'ai compris je suis largué ça
peut arriver parfois alors herbert
léonard êtes né en 1960 à bron soir
bonsoir
herbert le rvp en 1945 à strasbourg
votre vrai nom c'est leonhardt voulez
que je vous dise vraiment herbert vont
elles ont dit leur art
1 lenhardt voilà oui c'est très gerber
lenhardt alors 20 ans après votre
naissance après le service militaire ou
fait partie d'un groupe qui s'appelle
les jets et puis l aelies on souffre est
ce que tu te souviens des lionceaux
les lionceaux c'était des beatles
française avait des douilles comme ça
hein c'est humain il faisait que des
reprises des beatles allemand en
français en france précisons le précise
enlevée c'était vachement bien et je ne
savais pas et c'est vous aviez fait
partie des lionceaux j'ai fait partie
des lionceaux sur la fin parce qu'ils
sont passés un jour par strasbourg et
puis m'ont vu sur scène et comme je
cherchais un guitariste sont dit qu'un
celui-là il ya du matériel super mal
emmener avec nous et alors le le 3
janvier 66 herbert léonard fait la
première partie de chuck berry
à l'époque elle et ronnie bird ouais tu
te souviens de ronnie bird
c'était avec la frange et tewkesbury la
provoc mais vous savez ce qu'il est
devenu à vous laisser dire ça à maître
vergès
on ne peut pas vous laisser dire des
choses pareilles vous allez salut par
fait la tournée que j'ai fait c'est ce
qui est devenu le libère je crois
qu'elle a travaillé pour france 2 à un
moment donné il est à new york y revint
les appartements c'est incroyable ouais
je sais pas en fait je sais pas très
bien mais ce que ce dont je me souviens
c'est que dans cette tournée là il y
avait donc nous je vous rappeler les la
vedette anglaise
il y avait ronnie bird en vedette
américaine et c'était axe absolument à
mourir de plaisir
et puis aller chuck berry qui venaient
faire son boulot hein parce qu'il n'est
vraiment faire son boulot mais c'est
tout alors on 68 gros succès avec une
reprise de jane pitt n'est qu'on
retrouve air sur votre nouvel album en
duo avec karine lopez qui a gagné entrée
des artistes organisée par pascal sevran
sur france 2 parce qu'elles seront que
nous recevrons la semaine prochaine et
on 70 le duo jacques braun 70 c'est
l'accident vous raté un virage et vous
vous retrouvez encastré d'souza que vous
vous êtes défiguré été défigurée au mg
ressembler à frankenstein pendant un an
j'avais pas très envie de me regarder
dans une glace et je sortais plus quoi
je crois très et je me suis dit qu'à ce
moment là que le petit bout de carrière
que j'ai eue bas il était terminée quoi
c'est fini oui c'est quand vous êtes
revenu un an après il ya des mecs qui
étaient arrivés sur le marché vous aviez
plus votre votre place ça allait très
vite à l'époque on faisait un disent
tous les trois mois parce que ça
durerait pas plus longtemps et puis de
s'absenter un an comme ça sans rien
faire donc vous oublie tout de suite
quoi en tout cas le métier sérieusement
herbert léonard si vous n'aviez pas eu
cet accident
vous auriez une meilleure carrière vous
pensez j'en sais rien en tout cas ça m'a
été profitable ça vous a freiné dans
votre carrière
ça c'est sûr j'aurais peut-être mieux
fait de freiner à mon doigt alors à ce
moment là vous avez quand même après
votre accident une
êtes dépressif qui était c'est
compréhensible et vous vous en sortez
grâce à votre votre femme
oui cléo et à votre fille et les ah oui
parce que on a fait un enfant à ce
moment là les 3,5 à 7
et puis ça m'a enfin ça a été un
enchaînement de de tout quoi
ma femme qui me soutenaient parce que je
me tapais la tête contre les murs
france 4 les années c est bon je sais
que c'est pas bon mais quand même si
votre chien peu de femmes travaillaient
à l'autre bout de la france
donc vous voulez c'est vous qui créent
de l'argent puisque je pouvais plus rien
ouais et vous vous occupiez de votre
fille et c'est ça finalement qui vous a
donc il vise à redonner le goût de vivre
oui c'est equal pierre moment de cette
année là haut je crois que le pire
moment c'est de me voir dans la glace
scalper 1 avec des points de suture
parce que j'étais il faut dire que j'ai
fini dans une clinique une maternité en
fait non qu'on marque uzi avec des films
de toutes les couleurs et très très
grossièrement donc j'en garde encore une
claque pas les mots pas trop ça s'est
arrangé avec le temps mais jusqu'alors
comme une cicatrice ici même élégance
adore ça et je sais et et je crois que
le pire moment c'était justement de
quand je suis sorti dessous le camion
parce que j'étais encore conscient et de
voir dans la première glace que j'avais
en face de moi
en faisant ça et tout d'un coup en
voyant tous mes chevaux dans la main ça
c'était terrible
le succès reviendra en 1981 avec pour le
plaisir effectivement et en attendant
pendant les années 70 vous commencé à
écrire pour aviation magazine et vous
devenez le spécialiste mondial de
l'aviation militaire russe
c'est à dire kerber léonard c'est
insensé j'ai fait cinq bouquins le
premier faisait 500 pages il peser deux
kilos et demi qui peut l'arrêter sur les
effets sur les chasseurs vous avez écrit
effectivement sur les tupolev les îles
une chine ont des sukhoï et aujourd'hui
vous publiez un livre sur les chasseurs
polikarpov chez la rivière
un sens et c'est à dire que quand on
voit passe quand on retrouve voir à quoi
ils s'intéressent zoom zoom bon garçon
là si tu veux d'un coup c'est quand même
assez assez grave
c'est cette venue chez vous pratiquement
une perversion dans l'aviation militaire
relève selon victor mais la musique
érotique sur la chine refuse poliment
or les planètes bellay qui le prouvent
qu'il pourrait être un grand producteur
de télévision là tu viens de le prouver
non mais ça a un sens et si une
perversion chez vous non pour moi moi
j'appellerai ça une passion couet les
avions militaires russes c'est pas
première moitié du 20e siècle en plus et
de couleur gris métal non mais j'ai
découvert tout bêtement un jour chez
dans un couloir d'aviation magazine où
il y avait des milliers de photos qu'il
n'était pas classé une photo d'un petit
avion russe qui s'appelait le i 207 et
j'ai voulu savoir comment ce commet un
truc comme ça pouvait voler un et j'ai
essayé d'en savoir plus j'ai pas trouvé
alors je me suis dit plutôt que d'écrire
comme les autres sur les deux français
les anglais les allemands chez lui par
as tu sais les allemands savent
exactement ça fascine beaucoup je me
suis dit bas puisque personne écrit sur
les russes
je vais me spécialiser dans le flou
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont les les
policarpo à fond dit c'est le roi du
chasseur mais pourquoi c'est le roi des
chats pourraient c'est le roi des
chasseurs aujourd'hui parce que souvenez
looker c'est l'avion du poulpe frits
telle personne assez l'agent du pool
tout parent polikarpov le pool
personnage qu'est ce qu'ils ont de plus
stephen king avoriaz une guerre de 1936
en 1939 qui s'appelait la guerre
d'espagne et pendant la guerre d'espagne
sont sont apparus deux types de
chasseurs russes
le hic has et le i sez et cesser les
deux meilleurs chasseurs du monde à
l'époque et ils étaient russes fracture
parle de cul pour que les gens
reviennent
je te le dis pour toi c'est pour les
chiffres tu viens là mais toute façon
c'est pas avec les chasseurs russes que
vous allez revenir au top herbert